former New York Yankees superstar Derek
Jeter retired from playing baseball
three years ago but he hasn't left the
game Jeter is now CEO of the Miami
Marlins he spoke with CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor about the transition
from athlete to executive in his first
Network TV interviews since taking the
job here's a preview
you still Yankee fan I am yeah just not
if we're playing them right I mean this
is an organization where I owe
everything to and you have a great
relationship with the Steinbrenner
family but it's it's yeah it's it'll be
strange when we play the Yankees because
there hasn't been a day in my life that
I've rooted against them and you will
this year you have to root for your own
team on tonight's evening news Jeter
talks about the challenges of running a
team for the first time and tomorrow on
CBS this morning he shares the joy he's
found in fatherhood after retiring from
a 20-year career playing baseball yeah
he and his wife Hannah had a little baby
girl Bella last year and he said it
totally changed his life in all as we
all know in the best of ways what's more
challenging owning a baseball team or or
being CEO of a baseball team or being a
father and we would give him a pass we
understand why he wouldn't he will
always be a Yankee except on the day you
play Miami we get that Derek will always
be a New York Yankee there you got a lot
of people